Many imams recite the Quran in a very
fast way during the or
they also perform
and sujud in a fast manner which makes
it difficult for the followers to
supplicate properly. Is it allowed to
pray in this manner? It is very common
that many of the mosques because they
want to finish the full Quran in the
month of Ramadan in Taravi and they want
to make it as short as possible. So
people finish it. They do recite very
fast and very often you see that they go
in the sujud very fast and many a time
once I was in one of the mosques and
when the imam went in the sujud I went
after him. He got up again went again. I
was getting in my full sudjud and he was
doing a second sujud.
So is it right or is it wrong? It's
mentioned in Sai Bkari in number one in
the book of Salah had number 757 that
once the prophet he enters the mosque
and there is another man who follows
him. He offers the salah and after
offering salah that man he wishes the
prophet assalamu alaykum. The prophet
greets back and says that go back and
pray because you have not prayed. The
man goes back and he comes back to the
prophet. The prophet says go back and
pray you have not prayed again. The
person goes for the third time. He prays
and he comes back. The prophet again
says go back and pray for you have not
prayed for the third time. So the man
says I cannot pray better than this. Oh
prophet please teach me how to pray. So
then the prophet says that after seeing
takir
you recite while standing in aam as much
of the Quran that you know by heart
whatever of the Quran you know by heart
you recite then you bow down go in your
at ease and then say glory be to Allah
then stand up straight until you're at
ease then go in sujud with calmness
until you're at ease and then say Allah
glory be to Allah who the most high
thrice then get up again until you're at
ease and then continue your prayer like
that that means all especially your and
your sujud and when you get up from your
and in between the sujud you should be
at ease
you can't go up and down fast if you do
that it is as though your prayer has not
been accepted as though you have not
prayed. So if you pray in this fast
manner of taravi where fast fast it is
as though you have not prayed. So it is
best that you pray slowly with calmness
and if you really feel that you can't
offer 20 then offer it but with peace
with ease and with calmness the best is
that with peace ease and calmness and
long
should be long it should not be having
competition with the other mosques you
know which we have many times when the
many mosques they compete who is going
to finish the taravi faster